negotiations between Amazon and Mark
Fergus have broken down but there is
still hope
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
[Music]
so this video is going to be a recap of
the live video we did just Monday gone
um about the relationship between Amazon
and Mark fergus's company penguin and
Parker and where we're at with contract
negotiations for a new stargaze series
but also we're going to have a little
bit of extra information and some
clarity on a few of the points so let's
just get straight into it so apparently
the week commencing the 12th of December
last year there were a series of
meetings between Amazon MGM and Mark
fergus's company penguin and Parker now
Mark Fergus wasn't necessarily involved
with all these meetings it was members
of the team they were lower Executives
was also involved in some of those
meetings now these meetings are all
about putting together the final touches
on the preparation work before green
light so it's all about what would the
budget be what sort of actors are we
looking at to put in the show what is
sort of how many episodes very
preliminary storyboarding very
preliminary artwork all these sorts of
things it's all that to give a package
to put to the executives to say this is
exactly what we want to do I just need
your signature well crack on and get it
done
so these meetings carried on through the
week the end of that week There's also
then supposed to be a meeting directly
between Mark Fergus and Michael Wright
the head of scripted material at MGM
plus Jennifer Salk head of prime Studios
is also supposed to be involved in that
meeting now I'm told that at that
meeting there was a disagreement on
several points now
earlier in several meetings there had
been discussions about whether penguin
and a parka could handle these two big
projects that Amazon were giving them
obviously very recently it was announced
that penguin and Parker would be doing
the God of War series for Amazon this is
a big project for penguin and Parker and
they are going to be basically on the
same role in that that they did with the
expanse that they would be executive
producers they would write several of
the episodes and they would be in charge
of development now this is something
that I suspect they will also do for
Stargate that they will act as again
executive producers they will write
several of the episodes and they will
develop the series but then another
production company will actually make it
now that production company as far as
I'm aware has still not been found
so they have these doubts could penguin
and Parker do both
um Mark Fergus apparently very quickly
dismissed those concerns saying
basically I'm going to be doing Stargate
and Hawk ghost be my partner and crime
is going to be doing the um God of War
that really is his baby and Stargate is
mine my focus will be here his will be
there so those concerns were dismissed
quite easily but then as conversations
with what Amazon would like to do with
Stargate continued Mark Fergus began to
get more and more concerned they started
talking about doing a standalone movie
that would be separate from the TV show
something that generally he hadn't been
told about before he believed that he
would have developmental control at
least over the movies and the TV series
so that these two projects would work
together a standalone movie is not
necessarily an issue the Stargate
Universe is plenty big enough for lots
of Standalone stories he was concerned
that the project chicks would be
confusing for the audience and that if
they were too different be very
disjointed he was also then told that
the new TV series would almost certainly
be on MGM Plus in the United States and
not Amazon Prime now that was not
necessarily a major concern it was
something that we've all expected for a
while but he was also then told that it
would be on MGM plus around the rest of
the world as well now that was something
that Mark Fergus was not expecting at
the end of the day epics in the United
States that will become MGM plus shortly
is already an established streaming
service MGM plus around the rest of the
world however is not so well established
it's just really a bolt-on to Amazon
Prime that nobody really watches so if
this show appeared on MGM plus around
the rest of the world it really would
have a limited audience and that's very
concerning to myself and I'm sure it
will be to lots of gators well just like
it was to Mark Fergus but the real
problem
and the real thing that apparently Mark
Fergus really couldn't get past was the
budget they were basically telling them
that because this show was going to be
peeing on a smaller platform MGM plus it
would get a smaller budget he was asking
for something like 10 11 million dollars
an episode which would be around 120
million dollars for a 10 episode series
however they told him he's more likely
to get a budget of 60 million dollars a
season of 10 episodes 6 million dollars
an episode of absolute maximum now
because it's a streaming service they
could extend that budget by basically
making less episodes and that is always
going to be an option but he has
basically told they're ordering eight to
ten episodes and at a maximum cost of 60
million dollars so these meetings just
before Christmas ended with Mark Fergus
saying I don't think I can do that and
we need to have further conversations
now that is not what was supposed to
happen I'm being told these were
meetings were supposed to be the
finalization of the agreements that as I
say this package was supposed to be put
to the executives and they were supposed
to sign it off and then we could have
had the announcement by the middle of
January it's looking more likely now
however that that is not going to happen
the middle of January and it's actually
possibly going to be another couple of
months because these issues still need
to be ironed out now I've been told more
recently that meetings are scheduled for
next week that'll be from the 9th of
January 2023. and that those meetings
are again going to be with the lower
Executives and penguin and Parker's team
Mark Fergus won't necessarily be
involved in any of those conversations
directly they are going to be discussing
the budget and discussing how they can
work to what Amazon are hoping to pay
also there'll be discussions about
whether they can do things like maybe
have only five or six episodes initially
for this 60 million dollars and then see
how that series is received by us and
move on also there'll be descriptions
however about where Amazon planned to
put the series now normally that's not a
conversation that would be had between
the producers of TV show The streaming
service in this case Amazon the customer
will go to a production company and say
we want a TV show and this is what we
want however Mark Fergus has very
serious concerns about how the show will
be received and at the end of the day
it's his name that goes on it so he does
want reassurances that the TV show is
going to be given a a really decent Fair
crack of the Whip and will get seen by
people and to do that it really can't go
on MGM plus alone
now whether that means a limited run on
Prime just to get interest then it would
then be moved to MGM Plus or something
else is still up for negotiations but I
am told they are open to get this show
get made and they are listening to Mark
fergus's concerns
so where are we at right now
what a really dangerous Tipping Point it
could go either way Mark roses could say
you know what
I can't do this I'm just going to
concentrate on God of War
or
they could meet somewhere in the middle
they could get say seven eight million
dollars an episode Mark cougars might
have to cut some Corners he might have
to change his plans for the overall
season but we would still get something
made
Amazon could see the light and actually
just give him what he wants but that
doesn't seem likely and isn't really how
negotiations work anyway what I am told
is though that everything is still
possible nothing has been decided and
we're still really hopeful that we're
going to get this announced in the
spring now as I told you lots and lots
of times Stargate appearing on lots of
different networks and streaming
services is a good thing this is all
getting started into the public domain
lots of articles are appearing all over
the Internet about Stargate this is also
a good thing from my sources I know this
is disgusting marketing meetings
constantly and the sleeping giant of
sci-fi is regularly one of the big
topics
Amazon genuinely consider this to be a
flagpole project and something that they
think could be easily as successful as
Star Trek is for Paramount so it is very
likely this is going to happen however
I'm also being told that if it doesn't
happen now it might not happen for a
very long time and it might be put on
the back burner also if it doesn't
happen there we're at more and more risk
of a hard reboot instead of a
continuation of the story that we all
really want
so cross your fingers cross everything
don't forget to like and share the video
not just because that promotes my
channel it's obviously I want but also
because it promotes Stargate which we
really really want and get into the
comments
I want to know exactly what you think
about this news where are we going with
Stargate and what do you think the risks
are if it doesn't happen right now like
we hope
get into the comments and tell me
exactly what you think if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
the Bell notification it really helps us
out and you will never miss another
video also if you enjoy the channel and
you wish to support us further consider
hitting the join Button as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
good
[Music]